and there's lots of ways of
communicating with employees but for us
really we think the best communication
is not you know it's not communication
from the top down but it's communication
that happens naturally amongst friends
and so that's why we encourage ten to
twenty percent of people's times
especially if your manager to be spent
outside the office hanging out with
other employees and people that you work
with and sometimes when we do the new
hire sorry sometimes when we do the new
manager orientations and we encourage
them to spend another twenty percent
every time outside the office if they're
someone new then a reaction we get as
well as in that wasting time it's not
we're not really working but then we
asked people that have done it how much
more efficient as your team because
there's higher levels of trust
communication is better people are
willing to favors for each other because
they're doing favors for friends instead
of coworkers and the answers we get back
range anywhere from twenty percent to a
hundred percent so kind of worst case
scenario you break even but you're
having more fun
well so there's different ways of firing
employees and firing you know in some
cases is maybe even too strong a word
for example during the training program
at the end of the first week we make an
offer to everyone and the offer is that
will pay them for the time they've
already spent training plus a bonus of
two thousand dollars to quit and leave
the company right then and that's
actually a standing offer until they
enter training and we've extended it
even a couple months after that so
technically it's the employee making
their own choice on whether this is the
right company for them and in Las Vegas
starting pay for a call center rep is
eleven dollars an hour there's plenty of
other call centers so two thousand
dollars is a pretty significant amount
of money so we want to make sure that we
get employees that are you really
believe in the long-term vision of the
company want to be part of that and
really believe that this is the company
that's right for them from a culture
perspective and you know we do
occasionally have people that take that
offer and I think it's actually a
win-win for both sides
so in late two thousand eight we had to
lay off about eight percent of our staff
and that was actually a pretty tough
thing to do we were we were actually
still growing year over year but this
was during the whole financial crisis
and and we had planned for much more
growth than we actually had and so we
had hired into that and then we realized
that we weren't going to be making our
numbers so we ended up laying off about
eight percent of our staff and but we
wanted to do it in a proactive way most
companies were waiting until they were
forced to lay off employees when they
couldn't make payroll anymore or they
would lay off employees and give them
maybe two weeks of severance for us we
want to make sure we took care of our
employees and we actually gave everyone
at least two months of severance and on
top of that anyone that had worked with
the company for more than two years we
gave them one month for every year that
they worked at Zappos and then we also
covered their Cobra payments for six
months after that and it was really more
just make more about making sure that we
were proactive in taking care of our
employees and we were very transparent
and why we had to make that decision and
email that not only out to our employees
but posted it publicly on our blogs as
well and so I think for us it's one of
our core values is about being open and
honest and we tried to be as open and
honest as we could with all our
employees and made sure that we didn't
we weren't backed into a corner and
because we could have actually waited a
few more months but we wanted to make
sure that they got a decent amount of
severance instead of just doing what
most other companies seem to be doing
which was just letting them go with very
little severance
you